I start with a model, that I think it's
good to figure out your persistence,
figure out the objects that will be
in the model, write it and test it.
Once your model is in place, it's tested
enough that you're confident in it,
it's just much easier
to proceed from there.
>> So, once I have everything all
ready to build a new project,
my first step in Xcode is
>> File new project.
[LAUGH]
>> So the way I started out,
when I have an idea, is I want to sort
of validate the core proposition and
just verify that I can
actually build it.
So I just dig in as fast as I can,
I don't worry a lot about code quality.
I don't worry a lot about what
the final app is going to look like.
I just want to validate that
usually its inspiration and
that's what keeps me coming
back to finish the app.
>> So, when I'm starting to build the
app I think the most important thing is
to get from a to b as quick as you can.
>> I've done a lot of
different projects and
where I usually get stuck or
stalled is when I try to optimize for
every little corner case that might
happen, so taking what your idea is and
trying to figure out how to get to stage
one, version one of the app, just have
something that you can use and that's
usually what I try to build first.
>> I take a lot of time to read
the documentation and to make sure
the tools that I'm going to be using to
make the project are the right tools.
Sometimes you find that the tools
are no longer supported and
you have to pivot and
find something new.
Sometimes you find
something that just came out that's
better and easier to implement.
Sometimes you find the documentation
is really hard to read, and
you have to take more time
to just decipher what it is.
When I'm starting a new project
from scratch, I think of,
at first I try and
make a minimum viable product.
I think of the simplest version of
the app that I can possibly think of,
and then I build that.